[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe de chamonix pourrait fort bien
s'appeler cette année le grand prix de
descente en vrille des illusions perdues
il va y en avoir quelques une manière
originale de faire le mur d'ailleurs
cette partie du parcours c'est paraît-il
le mur du départ pas très catholique
cette descente
il accuse même aller plus loin que les
autres passons aux choses sérieuses
voici georges du billard un champion
c'est une pub lui qui détient le record
il a fait dix mètres de plus que ses
adversaires
[Musique]
un autre champion plus grand encore son
frère adrien du bia ouf
il est encore 2 et bien non décidément
il n'y aura personne à l'arrivée
rassurons les âmes sensibles il ya plus
de peur que de mal adrien du billard est
seulement un peu de rock
il a tout de même bien à qui va rester
sur ses skis
albert gars qu'on entretient un suspense
tombera tombera pas soyez tranquille
lui au moins il franchira la ligne
d'arrivée en quatrième position
là on retient son souffle
[Musique]
pour ce skieur rien n'est impossible il
porte le numéro un c'est bon signe
on appelle cela faire l'oeuf en termes
techniques
ce skieur c'est guy périllat aisance
décontraction sûreté des gestes
manifestement il ne veut pas tomber il
digère toutes les bosses avec un bel
appétit
[Applaudissements]
et
mais
quelques mètres encore obtient son
souffle
[Applaudissements]
lui aussi il est tombé mais au bon
moment après la ligne d'arrivée c'est
suffisant pour gagner
[Musique]
c'est un tocard de série du type
randonnée à rouler ainsi pendant 97
jours il ne s'est arrêté que pour
prendre du carburant changer de pneus
mais évidemment pour changer également
deux pilotes
neuf pilotes se sont relayés au volant
durant ces 90 7 jours à l'issue
desquelles ils ont parcouru 200 mille
kilomètres cinq fois le tour de la terre
à 80 5 de moyenne
tout cela sans incidence est la première
grande épreuve d'endurance de ce genre
contrôlée par l'acf une telle
performance valait bien les
félicitations du patron ce que
s'empresse de faire monsieur paul berry
il paraît que nous sommes là dans le
temple du rugby à twickenham ce temple
c'est un vulgaire terra bouées ou des
bulldozers serait sans doute plus à
l'aise que des joueurs de rugby maillot
immaculé pour les anglais du moins pour
le moment
mailhot foncé pour les français pour
être sûr de tenir debout et dont nous
les uns les on tient des individualistes
boniface et dupuy partout à la contre
offensive sans avoir besoin de tuteur on
est faible dans les tribus
deuxième mi temps les français
s'effondre
joli cadeau de la défense française aux
attaquants britannique un essai du
deuxième ligne
harding qui va être transformé par
wilcox larié robes drapées ans paraît
pouvoir in town dans les tribunes
réplique du berger à la bergère un essai
français qui va marquer crauste après un
beau coup de pied de recentrage de
rancoule essai transformé par vanier
match nul 5 à 5 7 équitable mais ne
parlez plus aux français du pape du rock
[Applaudissements]
les nouvelles installations qui
s'offrent comme l'un des plus beaux
fleurons de l'aéroport d'orly le premier
d'europe continentale ont reçu la visite
du général de gaulle
[Musique]
le président de la république inaugurait
ainsi quinze jours avant sa mise en
service la nouvelle aérogare kim et orly
à la mesure de l'avenir une des plus
frappantes réalisation française dira le
chef de l'état
début d'une journée attendue et
longuement préparé le premier ministre
français est venu accueillir à orly le
président bourguiba plus que d'une
visite
il s'agissait d'un rendez-vous à
rambouillet dans le calme de la
résidence présidentielle bien gardée des
indiscrets le général de gaulle allait
s'entretenir avec le président tunisien
[Musique]
long tête à tête d'abord plus tard
élargi sortira-t-il de cette rencontre
une esquisse d'une solution au problème
algérien chefs religieux entourée d'un
vaste traditionalistes souvent moderne
d'un état en pleine évolution
- médecins croient du maroc vient de
succomber brusquement à 52 ans son règne
un moment interrompues s'était raffermi
a surtout en 1955 ou des acclamations
unanime l'avait accueilli après un exil
de près de deux ans on peut dire qu'il
incarne à son peuple à un moment
difficile
[Musique]
après avoir négocié l'indépendance de
son pays il voulu assurer l'avenir de la
couronne en désignant pour son
successeur son fils aîné moulay hassan
aujourd'hui roi sous le nom de l'assam 2
on n'oubliera pas qu'il fût other
tragique de la guerre en ami sûr est que
le général de gaulle le plaça son côté
pour présider au défilé de la victoire
[Musique]
colomb béchar une fusée véronique
s'élève dans le ciel
atteindra 150 km mais durant tout son
voyage électrocardiographe et électro
encéphalographie n'ont cessé de
fonctionner un être vivant était à bord
dans son habitacle on l'a retrouvé en
bonne état le recteur car c'était lui ne
semblait pas se ressentir des 10
secondes pendant lesquelles au sommet de
sa trajectoire
son coeur avait cessé de battre
[Musique]
des milliers de moins de 20 ans venue de
belleville comme de la muette rempile
palais des sports à l'occasion du
festival du rock'n'roll pour vibrer à
l'unisson de chanteurs tels que johnny
hallyday qui ne pas 20 ans et non plus
[Applaudissements]
m
j'ai un métier il a pris ses quartiers
assez tardivement
et bim c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
à
et j'ai invité
des quartiers
j'ai le veston pays c'est le podium
francky jardin a aussi ses partisans
passionnés
[Applaudissements]
et on attend
à
non
rougeau presse
la boue
moi je te plaît
laurent cabrol est une passion d'une
religion une frénésie qui n'a pas
toujours sans casse
[Applaudissements]
as-tu est payante et al
las pour les poux mais moi je suis pas
jaloux
en plus d'heureux termine à 3 plus capé
sur nous dans quelques années ces
frénétiques sur un notaire épiciers et
percepteur et excellent père de famille
c'est au musée du costume dans
l'atmosphère de la mode romantique que
nous avons découvert la jolie madame que
présente pour notre été pierre dalm
silhouette souple dont la jupe est
courte sans excès ensembles fluides qui
glisse sans étrangler une taille qui se
devine mais n'est jamais marqué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les manteaux à manches kimono sont
fendues par derrière et s'orne souvent
de boutonnage très personnel
les robes met le buste à l'aise dans des
corsages légèrement blues ans
[Musique]
parfois aussi la robe s'agrémente d'un
corsage draper un bénitier ou repliés en
enveloppes
le mot d'ordre est toujours souplesse et
fluidité
[Musique]
après ces toilettes dans la ligne se
montre toujours prodigue d'invention la
ligne se gonfle pour le cocktail et le
dîner d'une ampleur modéré hauteur des
hanches
on aimera bien entendu ces tissus
aériens dont le charme garde un parfum
très romantique et à travers plus d'un
siècle les personnages d'époque n'y sont
pas tellement insensible surtout quand
des arcs-en-ciel de paillettes s'allume
sous les voiles des robes du soir
car avec elle s'anime les fêtes
merveilleuse d'une élégance qui évoque
les charmes des îles sous-le-vent de
l'asie des mille et une nuits en passant
par lan des raja et pourquoi pas les
fastes du second empire tels qu'on les
voit à travers un songe de parisienne
[Musique]
jolie madame de printemps oui jali
madame de paris
gardé par les cadets de l'armée
le couvert d'un temps de les tops brodés
qui ouvre traditionnellement la kaaba de
la mecque
le cercueil du souverain a été exposée
sur la place du mechouar en présence de
ses deux fils hassan de son successeur
et moulay abdallah entourant le
président bourguiba et des délégués de
nombreuses nations parmi lesquels
monsieur geoffroy de courcel
représentant le général de gaulle il
devait être ensuite placé sur une
prolonge d'artillerie pour être conduit
à sa dernière demeure
[Musique]
sur le parcours près d'un million de
personnes peut-être mêlant les larmes
aux gémissements les clameurs aux
invocations se pressait le long de ce
cortège immense que précéder les fils du
roi défunt
le président tunisien est le chef du
gouvernement sénégalais monsieur mamadou
dia
[Applaudissements]
foule exaltée au milieu de laquelle
s'abat parfois une forme humaine
au comble de l'émotion
trajet coupé par une pause à la mosquée
de yacoub el mansour dans les ruines
dominera da ou au milieu des colonne
brisée
le roi était venu faire sa première
prière à son retour d'exil
c'est dans l'enceinte du palais que
reposera le roi mohamed 5 dans le décor
traditionnel camp tour aujourd'hui un
maroc nouveau où les surprises ne sont
pas exclues
puisque la cavalerie moderne a remplacé
les chevaux d'autrefois par des motos on
ne s'étonnera pas que le motocross et
quelques rapports avec le jumping
c'est ainsi qu'au deuxième moto cross
international de barcelone qui
réunissait quelques uns des champions de
la spécialité
on a enregistré une succession de son
très réussi mon ange
c'est un véritable sport que se livrent
chaque soir les banlieusards de tokyo et
quel sport il s'agit pour plus de 3
millions de travailleurs de trouver une
place dans l'un des wagons du métro pour
nom d'un fn y parvient
et ceux qui parviennent à monter ne
peuvent pas se vanter de le faire sans
dommage si bien que le métro de tokyo
est en mesure d'ouvrir un marché de
chaussures et de boutons d'occasions
[Musique]
c'était autre chose n'a pas été sans
attirer l'attention des autorités
compétentes qui ont organisé une série
de conférences destiné à éduquer le
public
d'autre part pour mettre un peu d'ordre
dans ce désordre
on a établi une série de barrages propre
à fractionner le flux des usagers
enfin on a créé une brigade spéciale
qu'on pourrait appeler brigade de
compression
[Musique]
les employés qui en font partie sont
proposés aux différentes portières ou
leur mission est de faire entrer à
l'intérieur tout ce qui dépend
solution aux logiques sans doute
énergique sans conteste mais qui n'a
qu'un lointain rapport avec l'idée que
l'on peut se faire des commodités du
progrès
m
dans la salle du trône du palais de ryad
à rabat le jeune roi hassan 2 porté à la
souveraineté par la mort de son père
mohamed 5 adressé à la nation son
premier message dans lequel il s'affirme
le continuateur de la politique de son
prédécesseur
[Musique]
il devait ensuite selon le protocole
traditionnel
vêtu de la djellaba blanche et dans un
carrosse tiré par six chevaux se rendre
à la mosquée pour y présider la prière
du vendredi
ce geste traditionnel qu'ils
accomplissaient pour la première fois en
qualité d'iman des croyants a suscité
parmi la foule
un grand mouvement de ferveur qui
semblent plébisciter le début du nouveau
reine
[Musique]
e
on sait qu'à la suite des funérailles de
mohamed 5
le président d'ubs avait rencontré au
palais de rabat monsieur ferhat abbas le
jeune roi du maroc avait rejoint ces
deux personnalités pour participer à
leur conversation sur le problème
algérien
cette réunion s'est terminée par un
communiqué mentionnant qu'il n'existe
aucun obstacle à l'ouverture de
négociations directes entre le gpr à et
la france
les arts ménagers ont déménagé c'est au
palais de la défense qu'ils se sont
installés en notre époque de progrès il
va de soi qu'il s'adresse autant qu'à la
ménagère au chef de famille qui ne
saurait manquer d'y suivre son épouse la
découverte des mille et un ustensile de
fer par un libre service aux convoitises
des femmes pratiquent ne peut que lui
être agréable
il n'est pas non plus sans importance
qu'ils puissent tout savoir du maniement
du moderne tampon miracle qui nettoie
tout puisque somme toute il y a quelques
chances pour qu'ils le retrouvent à la
maison
il est également du plus haut intérêt
qu'ils sachent que les chaussures ne se
sert pas tout seul et que les produits
de première qualité ne seraient opérés
par enchantement le petit miracle
quotidien
[Musique]
e
m
le convient-il pas aussi qu'il n'ignore
rien de ces papier chiffon qui se jette
après usage et qui peuvent si bien
essuyer la vaisselle
que de choses à nespouls digne de ce nom
n'a t-il pas à apprendre aux arts
ménagers et n'est-il pas juste qu'il
soit à même de juger par lui-même du
poids de toutes les connaissances que
requiert la tenue d'un ménage le
répétons le messieurs une visite aux
arts ménagers ne peut que vous être
profitable vous y découvrirez d'ailleurs
la maison de vos rêves avec l'intérieur
de vos rêves et les fauteuils de vos
rêves
mais n'est-ce pas navrant de voir le peu
d'empressement que mettre les hommes
assez instruits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous nous improvisé acrobates d'un soir
dompteur inattendu se sont succédé dans
le cercle enchanté du cirque d'hiver
pour la 31e fois le gala de l'union des
artistes mettait en piste ceux et celles
qui d'habitude sont plutôt les autres de
la scène et de l'écran et un public de
choix celui qu'on aime le tout-paris
applaudi une nouvelle écuyère brigitte
aubert
[Musique]
le numéro de trapèze de jean pierre
cassel et françoise dorléac a pu faire
passer un frisson jean cocteau qui par
la cie parfaitement du cirque et jean
marais qui fut dresseur et acrobates
dans de précédents galas de l'union les
ont applaudis en connaisseur
narry dance a étonné tout le monde en
jouant les femmes serpent en compagnie
de quelques virtuoses de l'équilibré
[Musique]
et
quant à joséphine backert plus belle que
jamais elle a conduit avec une maestria
étonnante d'aller d'éléphant tout cela
pour venir en aide aux artistes dans la
nécessité et pour montrer que le
blogueur peut faire très bon ménage avec
le courage et le talent
c'est dans une atmosphère digne des
légendes orientales que s'est terminé le
voyage de la reine elizabeth dans ce qui
fut l' empire des indes
à bénarès elle devait être l'hôte du
maharadjah de la cité sainte qui
déployait en son honneur le faste le
plus fantastique 14 éléphants au
palanquin d'or et d'argent massifs ont
ramené la reine et son cortège jusqu'au
gange le fleuve sacré dont les eaux
enlève les péchés
au milieu des fidèles qui se plongent
dans ces eaux purificatrice la reine
parcourra le fleuve le long du quai ne
se développe avec son pittoresque
étonnant la ville qui est pour 200
millions de fidèles à la foi la mecque
et jérusalem est qui est la ville la
plus étonnante peut-être de l'inde
entier
c'est fini après une enquête qui aura
duré 3 129 jours la sphère peugeot a
trouvé son dénouement
les policiers ont amené à paris raymond
rolland et le reste de la banque
la blonde inglis bodine qui cachait son
visage et rolande biais musique enfouie
sous son imperméable visage découvert
pierre larche et le dur est sans doute
l'organisateur grappes et jean-simon
rotman l'étudiant qui prétend ignorer la
provenance de l'argent ravisseurs et
complice tous sont sous clé les
enquêteurs peuvent maintenant
reconstituer les détails du rapt du
petit eric on voit ici rendu à ses
parents après la remise des 50 millions
si l'on connaissait les détails de
l'enlèvement
l'arrivée du ravisseur par une brèche
dans la sève au golf de saint cloud où
l'enfant jouait tous les jours et leur
départ par la barrière on sait
maintenant que c'est dans cette maison
retirée des pieds russe qu'eric a été
séquestré
on a aussi retrouvé dans une voiture qui
stationnée dans un garage parisien une
partie d'une toute petite partie de la
rançon
6 millions d'anciens francs un autre
millions si l'on compte le prix payé
pour acquérir la vieille ferme de reuil
sur brèche future retraite peut-être
pour d'autres craignent le plus
singulier sans douté que megève ou une
ville a abrité les vacances de la
famille peugeot était en même temps
l'asile de la banque qui se logeait dans
ce chalet des six enfants où furent
arrêtés raymond rolland et ingrid bodine
on dit même qu'au restaurant la ferme
ils ont pu dîner à des tables voisines à
versailles
le commissaire denis a remis ses prix
aux juges renard chargé de l'instruction
[Musique]
bien marché va devoir méditer sur une
carrière dans le rapt du petit peugeot
n'était pas le début d'une glisse bodine
fausse miss danemark sur les dangers de
l'argent trop facile l'étudiant rotman
sur un thème analogues
quant à raymond renan puisqu'il méditer
sur le caractère odieux du crime qui
consiste à mettre en jeu la vie d'un
enfant
[Musique]
l'homme vient d'enregistrer un nouveau
record de vitesse
porté par un b 52 l'avion spatial
américain x 15 après avoir atteint 22
mille mètres d'altitude a volé à 4200 64
km heure
l'appareil qui s'est posé sur ses skis
dans le désert de californie aurait mis
neuf minutes 37 secondes pour passer de
la verticale de paris et celle de
marseille
il peut encore faire beaucoup mieux son
pilote le commandant bob white qui est
aujourd'hui l'homme le plus vite du
monde a échappé pendant 27 secondes à la
pesanteur
[Musique]
vivre c'est aussi pour ceux qu'on nomme
les diminuer physique la possibilité de
retrouver une vie active
monsieur bernard chesneau ministre de la
santé publique a inauguré à quetigny
dans l'eure le centre joseph arditi qui
répond justement à ce but et qui est le
premier du genre en france tout en
poursuivant leur rééducation les
paraplégiques peuvent ici serait adapté
au travail industriel et redevenir des
citoyens à part entière
[Applaudissements]
parent attention vous le savez les
jeunes enfants ont trop tendance à
porter à leur bouche tout ce qu'ils
trouvent
mais ce simple geste n'est pas seulement
contraire à l'hygiène il peut être bien
plus grave
il l'est d'ailleurs trop souvent pour le
constater il suffit de parcourir les
journaux pas de semaine kino relate un
drame de cette espèce intoxication
empoisonnement c'est la nécessité du
transport immédiat à l'hôpital encore
peut-on s'estimer heureux quand ces
accidents se limite à l'hospitalisation
or ces drames vous les côtoyer
quotidiennement pour que vous laissiez
les produits d'entretien à la portée de
vos enfants
c'est à dire le plus souvent à leur
hauteur au de javel soude acide mur y'a
tic
le bon ordre peut-être un autre résonner
dans le placard inaccessibles les
produits ménagers sont à l'abri des
convoitises
mais
et puis songer aussi à un autre danger
plus grave encore les médicaments dans
un tiroir ouvert ils sont tellement
tentant ces petits tubes tellement
entend ces bonbons qui n'en sont pas
quand on ne sait pas lire n'est ce pas
rien ne réfrène la gourmandise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis il y à la table de chevet et
c'est somnifères qu'on est tenté de
laisser à portée de sa main ce qu'il est
mais du même coup à la portée de toutes
les mains par an ne laissez jamais
traîner de produits pharmaceutiques
or de l'armoire à pharmacie mais pensez
aussi que les enfants ne manquent pas
d'astuce et qu'il y aille mieux qu'une
porte fermée une porte fermée à clé
comme lis pas demain dans les journaux
encore un enfant empoisonné
match à mohacs r moi
[Applaudissements]
deux combattants ne se font pas plus de
cadeaux que deux lutteurs sur harry tous
les coups sont permis surtout des coups
de tête
voici un magnifique et tremblements
comme au catch l'essentiel maintenant
c'est de ne plus lâcher prise
on se sert de ses pattes comme d'une
paire de boue l'adversaire ne s'en sort
pas il sera bien obligé d'abandonner le
combat sur décision de l'arbitré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
meron tout le monde descend et même
beaucoup plus vite que certains
concurrents ne le voudrait cette épreuve
c'est la dernière grande compétition
internationale de la saison
il s'agit du kandahar que la plupart des
champions considère un peu comme un
véritable championnat du monde un
championnat du monde qui ressemble
étrangement pour le moment un concours
de ce type
[Musique]
il paraît que ce n'est pas la meilleure
méthode pour gagner l'épreuve il vaut
mieux rester sur ses skis pour franchir
la ligne d'arrivée
[Musique]
passons maintenant aux choses sérieuses
avec guy périllat
perrillat c'est l'homme qui a gagné
toutes les grandes descentes de la
saison
alors pourquoi pas celle là
il n'a aucun complexe avec lui pas de
chute à craindre il a produit je sens de
l'équilibré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cent à l'heure il avale toutes les
bosses sans perdre une seconde
merveilleuse position
[Musique]
malgré son sourire périllat a trompé
tout son monde il n'a pas gagné la
descente du kandahar il ya deux
vainqueurs l'allemand wagner bergen
numéro 10 et l'italien albertine numéro
avant le départ du slalom guy périllat
n'est pas très rassurée pour la première
fois cette année il n'est pas certain de
gagner le combiné c'est à dire le
classement conjugués de la descente et
du slalom autrichien pepi stiegler prend
le départ c'est un concurrent très
dangereux pour périr
devait-il glisse entre les portes avec
beaucoup de vélocité sens en accrocher
une seule à vous de jouer maintenant
monsieur périllat vous savez à quoi vous
en tenir
le champion français a l'air de vouloir
forcer le destin
[Musique]
malchance périllat accroche de portes
qui vivent père de l' équilibre c'est
pepi stiegler qui gagne mais pas avec
suffisamment d'avancé cependant puisque
finalement périllat remporte quand même
le camp d'art le champion français est
bien le skieur le plus extraordinaire de
tous les temps
oh oui
[Applaudissements]
l'unité du commonwealth n'a pas résisté
à la politique de ségrégation raciale
qui sévit en afrique du sud et qui
dresse une barrière de tous les instants
entre le monde des gens de couleur et
celui des plans
mis en accusation à londres par les
autres premiers ministres du
commonwealth le docteur vers word malgré
les efforts conciliateur de monsieur
macmillan annoncé le retrait de son pays
la communauté britannique ne
comprendront plus désormais l' empire
que cecil rhodes avait bâti sur l'or et
le diamant en des temps où l'attribution
des lots de prospection se faisait au
plus rapide à ce qu'ils atteignaient les
premiers le témoin
[Musique]
dans les villes modernes cependant sans
le travail fourni par les noirs
l'afrique du sud ne pourrait continuer à
être ce qu'elle est la première
productrice d'or du monde
e
[Musique]
elles ne pourraient non plus continuer
d'assurer une production de diamants qui
lui permet de faire la loi dans la
fixation des cours mondiaux
oh
m
la défaite électorale du général ce
matin avait en effet laissé la voie
libre à la ségrégation raciale
avec le docteur malade puis le docteur
vers word engendrant des conflits
sanglants dont le docteur vers board lui
même si les frais
l'année dernière la révolte des noirs a
été on s'en souvient noyer dans le sang
violences qui sont le contrepoint de la
politique raciale
l'union sud-africaine pourtant s'enferme
dans son système
hier les électeurs c'est à dire les
blancs vont être à une faible majorité
pour la république premier acte
d'indépendance vis-à-vis de la
grande-bretagne
aujourd'hui c'est l'exil volontaire hors
du commonwealth
[Musique]
en france la grève des fonctionnaires a
été très suivie c'est du moins
l'impression qu'on pouvait retirer de la
manifestation des agents de l'état à
paris rue de rivoli où il n'était pas
question d'essayer de circuler à cette
occasion les agents de police ont fait
l'apprentissage de leurs nouvelles
fonctions d'ange gardien de la presse
tout d'ailleurs s'est très bien passé
les manifestants se sont contentés de
programmer leurs revendications devant
le ministère des finances
dans la perspective de l'ouverture des
négociations sur les bords du lac léman
on attendait avec anxiété en algérie la
fin du ramadan mais alger comme le reste
du pays fut en fait exceptionnellement
calme place du gouvernement la foulée
coutaller conteur d'histoires et les
joueurs de flûte
[Musique]
en tunisie depuis le retour du président
bourguiba l'atmosphère était à
l'optimisme après une absence de trois
semaines marquée par la visite au
général de gaulle à paris le président
bourguiba avait reçu dans sa capitale un
accueil triomphal
et la fin du ramadan descoings sider ici
avec la décision du fln de faire le
voyage du lac léman
cette décision les membres du gpr aggasy
de bentobal et ferhat abbas devait la
communiqué au président de la république
tunisienne
la fere algérienne entre maintenant dans
une nouvelle phase
[Musique]
en effet pourquoi pas nous vivons comme
chacun sait les rats tomic l'ère
spatiale l'air magnétique alors tenir en
équilibre dans l'espace par deux
électroaimants le sculpteur takis touche
aujourd'hui à ceux qui étaient hier
l'impossible
c'est du moins le sens qu'il donne à son
oeuvre de son perchoir perdu dans son
univers spatial
il communique son inspiration à des
disciples qu'ils formulent sur des
espaces déterminer la composition voulu
dont les éléments métalliques bien
entendu dessine sous l'action du champ
magnétique une mystérieuse symphonie
[Applaudissements]
oise audacieux peut être mais novateur
également cyril constantin bricoleur
acharné et inventeur à ses heures a
découvert son art en regardant un jour
un ouvrier se servir d'un pistolet métal
isr depuis dans son atelier
d'aix-les-bains lemaitre a mis au point
sa technique à l'aide d'un arsenal de
pistolets de chalumeau qui sont ses
pinceaux projetant sur son support les
méthodes son choix il obtient par
l'oxydation de ces derniers les couleurs
désirées
le maître ne s'en est d'ailleurs pas
tenu là pour faire vivre ces
chefs-d'oeuvre dans les reflets change
selon l'éclairage
il a construit un projecteur spécial
dont le jeu donne tout son sens à cette
oeuvre absolument incomparable
répétons nous pourquoi pas
[Musique]
on sait que les moeurs scolaires ont
admis aujourd'hui les classes de neige
ou le temps des écoliers venus des
villes se partage entre la poursuite des
études et l'initiation aux plaisirs du
ski c'est que l'école n'est plus ce
qu'elle était au temps de notre enfance
elle ne se contente plus de dispenser
l'instruction elle entend y joindre
dutil principes de santé ainsi à l'école
primaire de vendre c'est aux tout-petits
qu'on a songé pour eux après le déjeuner
la classe se transforme en dortoir et
l'on peut penser que cette expérience
des classes de sieste destinées à
rétablir l'équilibré perturbé par la vie
moderne est appelé un certain avenir
[Musique]
à la place des cantines les restaurants
d'enfants deviendront eux de véritables
classe de diététique ou en même temps
que les bonnes manières
les élèves apprendront à apprécier les
menus équilibrés et ce qui est important
les boissons sans danger on a songé
aussi à apprendre aux écoliers à lutter
contre la carie dentaire qui atteint en
france deux enfants sur trois au vésinet
une expérience est actuellement en cours
dirigés par le professeur el de
l'université de genève spécialiste de
médecine dentaire
cette expérience est appelée à approuver
l'action anti carrie d'un métal l'oeil
bien connu le fluor
en effet des expériences d'analogue
réalisés à l'étranger ont démontré
l'efficacité du fluor dans ce domaine
la visite en fin qu'a rendu le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur paye au lycée de
vitry-le-françois a mis au premier plan
une nouvelle technique pédagogique les
classes à mi temps qui verront les
élèves consacrer la moitié de la journée
à l'étude et l'autre moitié au sport non
l'école n'est plus ce qu'elle était elle
fait mieux
[Musique]
c'est maintenant devenu une tradition
l'élégance masculine subi le rythme des
saisons tout comme l'élégance féminine
et il n'est plus temps de faire la fine
bouche face au gilet de soi boutonnet en
travers qui nous guette au détour du
printemps ainsi en a décidé le groupe
des cinq dans la collection nous prépare
au petit audace des martingales et des
pantalons toujours sans revers mais
légèrement fendue sur le côté
[Musique]
serons nous condamner cet été à prendre
du galon et à nous laisser aller vers
ces délicieux couvrechef style tyrolien
modifié en paille tressée coup penchons
nous pour la tenue du gentleman cowboys
avec gilet bleu hérault bas de pantalons
relevés et ouvert sur le devant le plein
étaient des vacances quant à lui verra
le triomphe du blanc abondamment
galonnés avec chapeau un rapport
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas esprit d'avant-garde
trouveront peut-être trop classique
cette mode 61 les audaces ne manquerons
pourtant pas la garde robe masculine qui
adapte avec le smoking sport non plus
chapeau façon cow boy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans le cadre des nouvelles
installations d'orly que le général de
gaulle a accueilli le président de la
république gabonaise monsieur léon m'ba
second chef d'état de la communauté à
être l'hôte officielle de la france
après le président de sirhan
la visite du président demain devait
durer trois jours trois jours marquée
par des entretiens au palais de l'elysée
et qui se sont achevés par une soirée de
gala à la comédie-française trois jours
aussi qu'ils auront fait écho aux
paroles que prononcer le président de ba
sont arrivés tout gabonais à deux
patries le gabon et la france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce pari tout plein de secrets dizaine et
on paul fargue qui on connaissait
quelques-uns secret des judas secret des
mots de passe et nous voici dans un des
clubs les plus récents et les plus
fermés où se retrouvent entre eux gens
de lettres de théâtre et de cinéma
cette nuit pierre jean vaillard
coudoient jean pierre aumont et marisa
pavant
le dauphin et robert marchand imaginer
un sketch et dictent leur réplique
[Musique]
françois patrice et jean claude brialy
entourent michel morgo celle à minuit
des la sainte et studieuse du club
saint-hilaire musique
on dansera ce soir tout de même
plus secrets et moins fréquenté le club
des explorateurs sous l'oeil de
lapérouse chaque mois se réunissent des
gens que généralement on ne rencontre
pas à paris ils sont au mato grosso au
tibet en terre adélie haute hannezo à
chacun de leur passage ils se retrouvent
s'interroge se racontent un peu
gardinier vient de parcourir le beau
gars je suis et madame villaret arrive
dcn
les lieux tard est allé au pôle sud
jacquet petty villeminot ont appris à
lancer le boomerang avec les papous
d'australie centrale est un peu plus
loin bertrand flornoy rêve des sources
de l'amazone
sortons sur la pointe des pieds
tout secret toujours top secret même là
nous sommes dans un repaire de
flibustiers signe distinctif un vieux
doublons d'espagne les plaint des
châteaux en ruine les rébus laissés par
les capitaines davanture les testaments
devinettes et par des ancêtres
cachottier sont le thème de leurs
discussions
on tire des plans sur la bête de vigo et
l'île de la tortue à des cordes edgar
poe des personnages de mac orlan me
demandais rien de plus ses secrets
[Musique]
à l'occasion de leur congrès qui se
tenait cette année à turin directeur et
rédacteur en chef des journaux films et
d'europe ont tenu à visiter les travaux
de la prochaine exposition universelle
qui marquera le centenaire de
l'unification italienne le futur palais
du travail d'inspiration résolument
moderne peut être considéré dès
maintenant comme l'une des expressions
les plus étonnantes de l' architecture
actuelle
le salon des peintres témoins de leur
temps et maintenant un classique de
l'année est ce que c'est que dix ans
d'existence
aujourd'hui il a réuni sur le thème des
richesses de la france 100 exposants
autour de quelques grands aînés ou
légers grand-mère tiennent compagnie à
rouen ou chagall et ses étranges sirènes
d'un saint germain des prés saturé de
magie regarde dans la salle un fujita
naturel en contemplation devant un autre
îlot mathis est là lui aussi
et d'autres qui compte parmi les
richesses de la france et c'est bien
cela qui a compris un certain rené coty
qui les connaît bien
[Musique]
rien de commun entre ce statisques
figuratif que certains disent désuet et
cette exposition d'un art en marche qui
s'est ouverte à amsterdam
cet art en marche est d'ailleurs
consacrée au mouvement et même
pourrait-on dire au mouvement perpétuel
réussite parfaite et 6e salon artistique
fait un peu penser aux marchés à la
ferraille et au congrès des petits
inventeur farfelu c'est qu'on a l'esprit
mal tourné
l'un de ses appareils pousse même le
génie jusqu'à peindre lui même
chef-d'oeuvre engendrant des shader
tout cela fait du bruit bouge tresses
autre mutin de 13 hommes du grand-père
on vous dit et comme en vrai
35 chevaux au départ du grand national
de liverpool 28 millions d'anciens
francs au vainqueur
mais pour gagner il faut franchir sans
encombre les 30 obstacles répartis sur
les 7000 mètres du parc où tu es la
première es c'est le début de la grande
débâcle encore quelques concurrents deux
mois après le second obstacle à la
troisième mais on commence à y voit un
tout petit peu plus clair
ce cheval manifestement plus doués pour
les courses de plat a préféré changer de
parcours sans égard pour son jacques
restera-t-il un cheval et un jockey pour
franchir ensemble la ligne d'arrivée
oui ils sont tout de même encore 14 au
dernier obstacle
nicolas les éleveurs se détache dans la
dernière ligne droite et remporte
facilement le grand national devant le
vainqueur de l'an dernier
lorsque débute le match france galles à
colombes
les joueurs manifestent leur intention
de ne pas se faire de cadeaux on est
comme ça tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet les français qui joue un maillot
blanc culotte noire attaque premier
exploit de bouquets numéro 12 crochet
intérieur très classique coup de pioche
une touche qui se termine par le premier
essai du match
l'ambiance est créé la france va gagner
facilement
oui mais voilà sur le terrain il y a non
seulement quinze gallois qui jouent
contre les français mais également un
arbitre un arbitre qui voit toutes les
fautes françaises mais qui est
curieusement myope lorsqu'il s'agit
défaut de galles watts
quoi qu'il en soit les gallois n'ont pas
besoin de larbitre pour marquer leur
premier essai parfaitement plaît il est
en tout point identique à celui qu'ont
réussi les français au début du match 2e
mi temps voilà le moment qu'a choisi
larbitre pour provoquer la colère des
40000 spectateurs de colombes après une
course de 40 mètres bouquet passe à
boniface qu'ivana et entre les deux
tours
c'était magnifique pour tout le monde
sauf pour les arbitres l'essai est
refusé
un joueur français était hors jeu en
revanche sur cette attaque galloise
l'arbitré ne voit rien du tout en dépit
d'un en avant flagrant
résultat un essai pour le pays de galles
qui lui n'est pas refuser les français
dominent et pourtant les gallois mène
par 6 à 3
on se demande alors si la france ne va
pas perdre le match et la première place
du tournoi des six nations par ce pas
bien que paralysé par la crainte d'être
sanctionnés par l'arbitré
les français monopolisent le ballon et
joue presque constamment dans le camp
gallois
cette ténacité fini par être récompensés
et par un juste retour des choses c'est
boniface numéro 13 qui donne la victoire
à la france en marquant un deuxième
essai transformé par banier 8ce l'habite
[Musique]